Disney Dream Live Valley is out now in
Early Access on PC switch PlayStation
and Xbox and it's also included in Game
Pass and after a dozen hours in the game
here are 20 quick hitting tips to help
you keep your wardrobe stylish your
house fancy and your neighborhood full
of Disney and Pixar friends
the first thing you'll want to do is set
up Cloud saves enabling you to access
your save file across all platforms to
set up Cloud saves select the option
from the main menu and follow the steps
cooking food is a big part of Disney
Dream Life Valley and though you'll gain
new recipes for Missions you can happen
upon them by simply getting creative in
the kitchen so long as you use a
combination of new ingredients it's
likely you'll chance upon a new recipe
to add to the game's collection of over
100 different dishes
the best way to make money in the early
portion of the game is to sell food to
goofy at his farmers market like Stahl
high-end dishes can go for several
hundred coins or more and the
ingredients are more often free as they
grow around town or in your garden how's
that for profit margin
some of the story missions are locked
until you befriend enough neighbors plus
each neighbor has their own friendship
level with you ranging from 1 to 10. not
only does increasing these levels with
folks like goofy Remy and Scrooge McDuck
help unlock new missions but each
friendship level gives you rewards as
you level up that character the best way
to be social with others is to make
small talk every day bring them gifts
and ask them to hang out which makes
them tag along as a companion NPC and
steadily improves your friendship
together
as mentioned giving gifts is a great way
to get to know someone in Disney Dream
like Valley each neighbor will have
three items they're eager to receive
each day these could be particular food
items or Gems or something else entirely
interacting with each character will
tell you what they'd love to receive on
that day and giving them any of those
items dramatically improves your
friendship level just know that their
preferred gift will change each day and
you'll only receive the bonus the first
time you give them the item on any
particular day
in addition to many items showcased
around Scrooge's store you can select a
number of other clothing or Furniture
items by talking to Scrooge unlike
Animal Crossing ordering items is
instant no more having to wait until the
next day to get what you really want
often times digging and mining around
town will net you lumps of coal this may
seem like a throwaway item that gets in
the way of nabbing the good stuff but in
actuality you need coal to cook so don't
discard it
the number of items overall in Disney
Dream Life Valley is staggering from
recipe ingredients to minerals to
crafting items and more it can be
difficult to remember where each item
originates thankfully the game offers a
shortcut head into the collection menu
and highlight in item such as clay or
oregano you'll be told exactly where you
may find that item keep in mind most
items are not universally available
across all biomes this means some
crafted items recipes and other things
you may want to make might not be
available until you unlock the right
location in which you can find its
missing parts use the collection menu we
mentioned to ensure whatever it is you
want to build or cook is actually
already available to you
it's important to know where your
neighbors are at all times you know in
case you want to hang out or give them a
gift or complete a quest thankfully the
in-game map reveals character locations
in real time you'll see them move around
the map whenever you're looking at it
which helps you track them down quickly
and get on to the next part of your
adventure
unlocking Realms requires dream light
which operates sort of like Nook miles
in Animal Crossing they're earned by
completing a never-ending list of
challenges there are four available
Realms at launch in each door to one of
these Realms can be unlocked redeeming
dream life you should do these as soon
as possible as they open up new story
missions that end with characters like
Remy Wally and Moana moving into your
neighborhood more neighbors means more
friends which in turn means more things
to unlock
in addition to Bringing characters to
your town as neighbors you'll also want
to complete Realms because they teach
you new things and Grant you upgrades
for example during the Moana realm
missions you'll receive a free upgrade
to your pickaxe courtesy of Maui making
it able to break tougher rocks that may
drop crafting items or simply standing
your way each realm is a multi-purpose
mission that goes beyond simply
exploring a Disney World you may already
adore
this one took us by surprise in a good
way you can layer some furniture items
combining Furniture like this allows you
to build onto the foundation of nearly 1
000 Furniture items already in the game
at launch it makes it so that even if
two people like several of the same
in-house items they may end up with very
different styles which is a really
satisfying touch in a game like this
as you play through the game you'll
level up which most importantly improves
your stamina allowing you to mine garden
and perform other strenuous tasks for
longer periods without a break though as
we'll explain in the next section those
breaks aren't too intrusive anyway
when you run out of stamina you can
easily refill it in a few ways eating a
basic food item such as a piece of fruit
will replenish some stamina but to
refill the whole stamina bar at once
you'll need to head home simply stepping
inside your house but only your house
not your neighbor's homes will instantly
refill your stamina the world of Disney
dreamlike Valley can get a bit bigger
than the world of Animal Crossing so
this would be tedious if not for the
wishing well fast travel locations
you'll unlock in each biome use those to
get home faster and take a breather
filling your stamina bar is nice and
sometimes crucial but even better is
overfilling it you can do that by eating
high level meals such as Ratatouille
you'll see your stamina bar fill up in
blue as normal but then a second stamina
bar will fill past that in yellow making
you sort of like an overpowered boss in
a more combat heavy game but don't worry
in dream life Valley no one is coming
for your head
each friend you make can be assigned a
role which essentially acts as a buff to
the things you'll already be doing like
fishing Mining and gardening and you
should consider giving different friends
different roles so that you're always
receiving a buff just remember to
receive that particular buff you'll want
to be actively hanging out with that
friend who you've assigned the
corresponding role to
games like this love making you work
within stringent limitations to start
teaching you to chase upgrades one of
those upgrades you'll want fast is the
backpack upgrade trading some coins
while looking inside your backpack will
expand your inventory by another seven
slots which you can do up to three times
that means you can eventually double the
size of your backpack which comes in
handy when you're spending long days
foraging and crafting
one of the coolest features in dreamlike
Valley is the ease at which you can
customize your town simply by going into
the furniture menu while you're Outdoors
or indoors if you want to alter your
home lets you rearrange the town however
you see fit this includes totally
uprooting your home your neighbor's home
or even businesses the entire town is
yours to shuffle as much as you want and
you can do it all for free at any moment
whether you're looking for your Founders
pack Cosmetics or perhaps another
surprise it's a good idea to check your
mailbox often just like an animal
crossing you'll know you've got mail
when the mailbox flag is raised so if
you see it sticking up hurry over and
reveal what kind of gift or purchase
items you may have received and that's
it hit the comment section and let us
know some Secrets or tips that you found
during your time in dreamlike Valley
follow me on Twitter at Devonte Chisholm
and we'll see you in the next one
foreign
[Music]